how you doing alex
good rich how are you doing good buddy
hey just quick question about uh i've
heard you say something in the past
about make your wounds your work yeah
would you
how would you factor that into a
business or an health business
that's a good question um
well we can use my youtube channel as a
good example you know i started it out
as entrepreneurs and cars wanted to
interview my friends and their success
rides around friends with cool cars
pretty quick so i started talking about
how i would use lawyers in my business
how i would use parties to hire people
a lot of these ideas and then one day
somebody said to me you should do a
video on the kind of women not to date
i'm like well that's a wound in my life
okay so i made that video now all of a
sudden when i started talking about
something that was real and authentic
and was painful you know to me from
stupid [ __ ] that i'd done in the past
for some reason that resonated with
people and normally when i would upload
and publish it would either be crickets
or a hundred views maybe a thousand
views was big
that video got me a hundred thousand
views within a few weeks
right it's like and then i realized huh
if you make your wounds your work you
can probably turn it into something so
that's just one example right right um
buddy of mine brad uh sold his toy
company
and
wanted to get involved with um
more green projects you know like it was
a wound for him sort of thing so he
invested in and started up a business
that does uh biodegradable phone cases
you know sort of thing
not like you know something in his past
hurt him or a girl or a relationship or
a divorce or something like that a lot
of stuff you know guys turn to when they
end up coming to
you know like some of the videos that
have been on my channel in the past sort
of thing but it's just like i don't know
figure out where
the intersection of something that
you're passionate about like if you take
three circles it's like something you're
passionate about
something you're good at and then
overlaps on the bottom as well is
something that makes money
okay yeah okay
when those three things intersect
passion good at and make money and they
intersect in the middle that's where the
gold is right yeah and
for some people they can manufacture it
they can plan it they can set it up and
they can knock it out of the park you
know within six months
for me
i kind of fell into it you know like the
wounds and work thing
sort of stuff it's just like i ran out
of friends with cool cars to interviews
and it was really hard to edit those
videos and there was not enough reach
and views and income you know at any
point whatsoever where it actually made
sense to keep doing it so it's like i
like doing the videos and i want to talk
about stuff and i thought that
um the feedback that i was getting was
good enough that i should keep doing it
but it's like
you really get
get like that frying pan to the forehead
moment when you upload a video it's like
everything else is like a hundred views
or a thousand views and this one has a
hundred thousand views and you're like
wow okay i can talk about more of that
because i've done some stupid [ __ ] in my
life so
i'll share some of those stories and
people started wanting to talk to me and
booking me for consults okay well i can
charge them for that time because i'm an
expert right yeah
so you know just kind of like
build off it sort of thing
so there's there's there's a good hour
and a bit probably an hour and a half of
material in the lectures that talks
about how to build on youtube like
i i cover many different examples in
there like it doesn't have to be
anything remotely close to what i was
talking about i was talking to one of
the guys earlier today about
doing vlogging videos on his motorcycle
yeah
okay
okay cool thanks a lot man that really
helps appreciate that hey guys i really
hope that you enjoyed that short clip if
you did consider supporting the creation
of content by checking out my supplement
line pinned in the top comment below of
this video in the comments there's a
link to the unplugged alpha dot com
forward slash shop when you click
through you'll be able to land over here
and the entire lineup is broken down by
category that it performs best in
estrogen metabolism fat burning your
foundational essentials for health
immune health performance and
testosterone support if you check out
with coupon code alpha 10 you'll get 10
off on your first order there's also the
option to use the subscribe and save
model or regular shipments will be sent
over to you on a regular basis and that
gives you a little bit of a discount and
your supplement facts are always broken
down over here thanks for watching i
hope you guys have an awesome day and
again check out that link it's pinned in
the top comment below in this video
peace out
you